scp-035 versus scp-173  the evil possessive mask versus the  murderous sculpture these objects are a  lot less inanimate than they should be  but are they evenly matched the biggest  advantage that scp-035 has over 173 is  the fact that it doesn't have a neck  that the sculpture could squeeze or snap  meaning that 173 definitely couldn't  kill the possessive mask however given  that scp-173 doesn't have a traditional  mind body or face we can't really know  for sure whether 0-3-5 would even see  the sculpture as a desirable host a  fight between these two may just result  in a somewhat hilarious side of them  both just sitting around not moving in a  room together we'll call it a draw  really